ces reportages de robert papin et pierre
verney ils n'ont guère l'habitude de
manifester pourtant ces futurs hauts
fonctionnaires contestent une décision
de l'état comme l'a fait remarquer notre
directeur il s'agit moins de contester
que d essayer d'éclairer une décision
qui ne semble pas approprié nous pensons
que la concertation aura lieu que nous
aurons le moyen d'exprimer notre
opposition
pourquoi ce transfert ne semble
dangereux pour l'avenir de l'école et
d'envisager les possibilités de réformes
que le gouvernement pourrait les
premiers concernés ces candidats venus
passer leur grand oral aujourd'hui mais
déjà investi par le devoir de réserve il
ne s'exprimeront pas sur le transfert de
l'ena à strasbourg
les reçus commenceront le 3 janvier
prochain mais ces deux élèves des
sciences politiques qui rêvent un jour
d'être énarque espèrent que leurs
futures grandes écoles
restera à paris les relations entre les
naïfs sur ce pôle dont quand même très
importante et on a plus essayé de voir
si on pouvait pas s'organiser
directement entre ces deux écoles pour
réussir à empêcher cette aberration la
décentralisation c'est quand on prend
des coups à alicia centrale et pour les
donne aux collectivités locales
ce qu'on est à l'intention de faire pour
l'ena c'est pas de la décentralisation
c'est la délocalisation celle du
déménagement de fonctionnaires c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose mais qu'il se
rassure 80% des énarques font carrière à
paris un jour ou l'autre il y
reviendrons